il ne fallait pas être en retard au
stade de l'as khroub cueillis à froid
dès la deuxième minute de jeu les
alimentaires se font surprendre sur
l'ouverture du score de la parisienne
shirley cruz cette première mi-temps
entre montigné le psg se résume à une
attaque défense les coéquipières de
kenza dali sont supérieurs techniquement
et physiquement aux inimitiés avec une
circulation de balle à une ou deux
touches
les espaces se créent à l'image de ce
débordement côté gauche de la défense
saint-quentinoise laisse un boulevard à
l'exceptionnelle laure boulleau qui
délivre un modèle de centre en retrait a
augmenté les vertes n'arrive pas à se
donner de l'air est rentré dans le camp
parisien balle au pied aucune occasion
en première période
l'addition social très vite 3 4 puis 5
buts à zéro après les 45 premières
minutes conclue par ce bijou de coup de
pied arrêté signé l'insee orale
au retour des vestiaires bis repetita
le psg version qatar gère son avance et
accélère le jeu à sa guise de quoi
donner au score une allure de baby-foot
grâce au triplé de lune c'est orane pour
étriller les vertes 9 buts à 0
il faudra attendre les dernières minutes
de la rencontre pour voir les signé
monteyne obtenir leur première occasion
de but
la tête de margaux robin réchauffe les
300 spectateurs mais n'inquiète pas la
gardienne parisienne est juste de
jordanie grosset pourront se consoler en
se disant qu'il y a deux ans elle avait
perdu 13 à 0 face à l'olympique lyonnais
en 16e de finale les féminines du psg se
déplaceront à tour le 7 février
pensionnaire de division d'honneur